en face de vous il yal berric du monde
vous êtes le vice-président de la manif
pour tous
et parmi vos nombreux combats on
retrouve évidemment la pma pourquoi êtes
vous contre la paix m'a alors fait on
n'est pas contre la paix mais on est
contre la pma en l'absence de père c'est
à dire que aujourd'hui ce projet
d'extension de la pma plaisir fait un
contexte où on va priver délibérément un
enfant de son père on va dire
aujourd'hui on va utiliser physiquement
en disant toi injustement va te priver
d'un père tuera de mer mais ça ne
remplace pas un père et une mère
et aujourd'hui on est tous autour de
nous et je pense que si on pose la
question aujourd'hui au jardin public
on a tous des gens qui n'ont pas connu
leur père par ce qui est décédé parce
que c'est des couples séparés et la vie
apporte son lot de souffrances et
aujourd'hui cette absence de père c'est
une injustice et nous pour faits non
cette injustice en se disant pas
pourquoi ces enfants-là eux n'auraient
pas le droit à un père c'est la seule
raison
abbas et la note raison c'est d'exister
d'ailleurs c'est l'intérêt supérieur de
l'enfant
et c'est la seule raison pour laquelle
on se manifeste et on manifeste depuis
de nombreuses années alors je ris crevel
vous êtes d'accord donc par vous êtes
vous êtes contre la pma je dis pas vous
êtes d'accord ac alberico en tout cas
vous allez en contre pourquoi bas eric
et est d'une limpidité gré céline j'ai
juste rappeler une chose c'est que
nombre d'égalité des couples homosexuels
enfin lesbiennes peuvent avoir lesbiens
peuvent avoir des enfants mais si on
poursuit cette idée de l'égalité entre
l'homme et la femme alors il faut tout
de suite ouvrir la question de la gpa je
regrette c'est pas c'est pas le débat
pour après demain c'est le débat
aujourd'hui parce que les hommes dans
ces cas là au nom de l'égalité hommes
femmes devraient également avoir le
droit d'avoir une mère porteuse
et là on rentre dans des considérations
de marchandisation du ventre donc au nom
de l'égalité si on suit si cette loi
s'impose comme elle doit s'imposer bien
il faudra dans la foulée je regrette je
ne lis pas évidemment on sent quand on
voit ce que je pense mais donc il faut
se poser tout de suite la question de la
gpa et ne pas dire non le débat de la
gpa n'est pas du tout est ouvert
c'est juste le débat sur le pm alors ya
une question pour eric naulleau il ya un
an plus tôt alors mes eric naulleau de
la nature se pose aussi parfois aux
couples hétéros dans ce cas le non plus
ne devrait pas avoir de recours puisque
la nature leur refuse un enfant non
alors c'est la question que vous pose
lorsque j'ai expliqué ça dès le début et
moi je suis favorable à la pma pour les
couples hétérosexuels au cas où il ya un
problème de
de fertilité j'ai tout de suite précisé
que j'étais hostile à l'extension de la
pma mais pas à la pma en tant que telle
non pas du tout karim n'est pas je ne
comprends pas les arguments d'eric les
deux eric d'ailleurs parce que je pense
les élections le terrain de l'égalité
que le débat doit avoir lieu je suis
désolé de le dire
c'est sur le terrain du désir d'enfant
et de ce que la nature accorda une femme
elle n'accorde pas à l'homme
je suis désolé on va pas refaire la
nature humaine un homme ne peut pas
enfanter une femme en a la possibilité
est ce que la science peut aider une
femme seule à enfanter la réponse est
oui pourquoi l'en priver je ne comprends
pas en ouvrant droit
est ce qu'aujourd'hui la conception de
la famille telle qu'elle a toujours été
dans une tradition ancienne avec un père
au présent et autres est une conception
infaillible la réponse est non
énormément aujourd'hui de femmes et
leurs enfants tout seuls est ce que pour
autant les lèvres mal n'ont pas toujours
et un père physique option est ce que la
présence d'un père parce que il ya un
père physiquement est-ce que ça a sur la
la le rôle d'un père non c'est plus que
ça sont un besoin chez les dames où se
trouvait la passion excusait de primes
payant sur l'issue positive est une
femme est capable de l'emmener jéricho
une charge s'est posé une question karim
la gpa tu serais pour où tu serais je
suis contre la grc ou alors c'est alors
ben non il nous faut savoir expliquer ce
qu'est la gpa s'il vous plaît parce que
pour les personnes qui nous rejoignent
les corps et se servir du du corps d'une
femme pour faire un enfant pour un autre
couple et sa éventuellement un couple
d'homosexuelles je suis totalement
comblé pourquoi ce com commercialise la
pour autant le ventre d'une femme sur sa
date si je suis ton raisonnement avoir
la possibilité d'avoir un enfant et non
parce que une femme seule qui ait le
désir d'enfant c'est pas pour le mettre
à disposition de qui que ce soit c'est
pour l'élever métier pour lui donner de
l'avenir ouais mais les experts aux
hommes d'avoir des enfants d'albert à un
homme seul qui aurait le désir d'avoir
des enfants mais la nature ne l'ait
perdu 20 avait coûté que la question du
désir des adultes un homme qui veut
absolument et qui a le désir aussi
profond respectable soit il d'avoir un
enfant dans ce cas là vous lui accordez
ans d'avoir accès à la nature notre à
l'homme j'ai des papillons blancs non la
même
deux femmes ensemble non plus chez nous
juste de petites choses qu'il ya bien
d'autres jellicoe qui ce retour depuis
tout à l'heure ils disent pourquoi il
faut un débat pour ou contre le pmu non
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
je suis pas bon et se prennent la tête
pourquoi c'est ben laden sur le pmu quoi
ça règle sa maîtresse le monde d'accord
j'aimerais avoir l'avis de bernard
laporte à tulle je partage totalement ce
qui est de dire qu'à partir du monde
d'abord ou dans la loi sur le mariage
pour tous on a 10 de femmes peuvent
adopter un enfant comme de gens peuvent
adopter un enfant
il faut du bon sens ça veut dire se
couvre à ce moment là il a le droit lui
aussi fait ses deux femmes ont le droit
de dire je veux un enfant médicalement
assistée berne avec ledroit l'a alors
est sidéré mais c'est si ça peut tirer
sur un 10 réuni de 10 et la nature ne
permet pas les choses oui oui oui oui
mais non mais je réponds mais je mets
deux ans ne trouve pas les voir enfin
pouvoir suivre la voie et écope donc y
remédier et bien quelques coupes ne peut
pas en avoir
c'est naturel malheureusement d'accord
moi la tendresse ne peut pas avoir d'un
fan c'est naturel mais d'abord pourquoi
n'autoriserait jamais rien j'observe la
nature avait à fait que malheureusement
ya une fertilité il ne peut pas avoir
d'enfant c'est la nature comme tu dis
est touriste fonctionnement oui le même
assez la nature c'est comme ça
dysfonctionnement n'a été autorisé mais
c'est parce que c'est pas l'observent
que la plupart des débats se conclut
toujours par la même manière par le
désir je le désire donc tout doit se
plier à mon désormais qu'une femme et un
désir chez logiciels et j'ai le droit
maintenant c'est maintenant c'est
laisser les martingales j'ai le désir
j'ai le droit fin du débat ben non ce
sont quand même des débats de société on
peut pas tout réduire à des volontés
individuelles a des désirs individuels
voire à des caprices
là on a le droit comme quoi ça pénalise
la société c'est ça que analysions vous
entendez voir les i alors je disais
juste que c'était pas du tout un caprice
je vous défie pas apprécié voir des
caprices de ses proches un stop oui
c'est le prochain stade nous on est pas
du tout là on est sur des projets
parentaux qui sont
il réfléchit pas ça n'importe où
n'importe quand n'importe clip sur
thierry wident eric on a l'impression
que tu refuses des avancées on est en
2010 tient peut être oui
le projet a dit voilà c'est un projet
dont on n'avait pas forcément le progrès
la science sur le permet d'alterner donc
il faut lutter sienne désir que la
science ce permis et que ça apporte un
plus dans le bonheur des gens pourquoi
tu veux tu reposer alors qui des causes
aussi qu'on voulait réagir mais alors
c'est vrai c'est donc c'est vrai que je
suis plus branché pmu et city oui mais
est-ce que vous donner priorité aux
enfants orphelins
alors effectivement quand on a adopté la
fin adapte faire connaître quand on a
approché la pma on s'est dit pourquoi la
pma et pourquoi pas un autre biais alors
il ya la coparentalité
il ya effectivement il ya l'adoption
mais aujourd'hui en france on sait très
bien que les enfants adoptables sont
très peu nombreux finalement il ya
toujours un lien à la mer comment dire
biologique et il reste quand même très
fort donc finalement c'est c'est très
compliqué pour nous c'est très compliqué
on est face à un mur effaçant le mur
quand on a un désir qui est plus fort
que tout parce que le désir de vouloir
porter un enfant de l'élever de l'est
mais on me prend aux tripes
oui une femme peut comprendre jours à
lever le comprendre à votre wii
comprenez que nous on veut fonder des
familles on veut aimer nos enfants si on
veut l'emporter géante et organismes
alors halle berry d'options est beaucoup
plus long alma levé rick juste vous êtes
le vice-président de la manif pour tous
je leur dis pourquoi anne par exemple
n'aurait pas le droit pour vous d'avoir
un enfant mais on n'est pas dans une
question de droit et je respecte
parfaitement l'histoire dame et je ne
suis absolument personne pour me
permettre le moindre jugement j'ai
jamais juger personne jusque là et c'est
pas ce soir que ça va commencer la
question je pense qu'on peut la résumer
en termes de chiffres quand on demande
aux français
est ce que vous êtes favorable à
l'extension de la procréation
médicalement assistée
une majorité de français sont pour en
revanche sondage ifop de la semaine
dernière quand on demande aux français
est-ce qu'il faut que l'état garantisse
aux enfants nés de pm a le droit d'avoir
un père et une mère 82 % des français
sont d'accord avec cette affirmation
donc en fait c'est là qu'on se rend
compte déjà beaucoup de français ne
savent pas ce que c'est que la pma et
non parce que quand on leur présente
l'argument de l'amour et qu'on leur dise
qu'on peut ouvrir des droits
les français sont toujours pour ouvrir
des droits
on se rencontre et du livre vous ne
parlez que droits que tout à l'heure moi
je parle d'intérêt supérieur de l'enfant
et quand on se rend dans pouvant dériver
supérieur d'un enfant délibérément et
volontairement béribéri albert et aucune
étude
oui qui démontre aujourd'hui williana
enfants élevés par une femme seule est
moins épanouie
- d'équilibré moins heureux est avocat
jusqu'à décès dans la famille c'est
qu'un reportant le débat quand on aura
ses études appliquons un principe de
précaution qu'on applique parmi noms
mais les études à exister prouver ce que
vous dit navi à lorient et à tweetie un
tweet qui rebondit là dessus j'ai grandi
sans père cause de décès macho
exactement ce que disait quand j'étais
bébé
ma mère a su m'apporter la sécurité
parentale dont j'avais besoin
certes on a besoin de repères masculin
et féminin qu'on cherche chez papa maman
moi perso j'ai été chercher ce repère
chez mon frère on le cherche ailleurs
voilà mais là la situation est
complètement différente parce que ces
personnes là elle a une généalogie elle
a une histoire un enfant c'est comme un
arbre il faut qu'il grandisse avec des
racines
aujourd'hui ces enfants qui seront né de
procréation médicalement assistée sans
père ils ont connaissance d'un dossier à
leurs 18 ans si leurs mères veulent bien
et c'est ça le problème aujourd'hui
là la situation de vous nous parler
c'est bien ne connaît le nom de son père
c'est quelle est son histoire son
origine
là il ya cette question d'accès aux
origines qui est un drame pour bombarder
enfin j'aimerais qu'on a aujourd'hui
reconnu christine kelly qu'on n'a pas
entendu sur le sujet et mehdi ça fait
huit ans que j'ai une association qui
aide des familles monoparentales 85% de
ces familles sont des femmes
tous les psychologues disent que c'est
très important comme le tweet qu'on a vu
un peu comme ce que vous avez dit
d'avoir un repère masculin ce qui
n'empêche pas effectivement que par
exemple madame qu'ils puissent avoir un
repère masculin qui n'a pas quand on
mesure on est un tati hétéronormée avait
hasard un ami c'est important peau comme
il dit l' équilibre de l'enfant damas
hors pairs masculins
ça n'empêche pas madame d'avoir un
repère masculin albéric ce sont vos
convictions religieuses qui vous font
prendre une position de soyez honnête
non moi c'est du conditionnel
je suis tout ouïe et olic également donc
ça n'a rien à voir avec les femmes en or
les jalons de la police alors que la
question de révéler intéressante la
piste aux arrêts non mais vous savez
nous on est des simples citoyens a
présenté la manif pour tous depuis six
ans comme des réactionnaires les croisés
du nouveau monde et je ne sais quoi on
est des citoyens lambda je sens beaucoup
plus
et non mais c'est vrai ce que vous est
ce que c'est une opération comme halle
berry parce que c'est vrai que la manif
pour tous
ça fait peur à beaucoup de monde
derrière et on parle de vous comme des
parfois des idées extrémistes comme
voilà et c'est vrai que la joue plus
apaisé la maif pour tous les jolis coups
fondée en 2012
c'est exactement le même depuis invités
mois plus souvent vous verrez que je
suis aussi détendu tous les soirs que
vous voulez non mais c'est sympa de
pouvoir c'est aussi et syrie les jours
et vous remercier parce que c'est aussi
l'une des rares fois on peut avoir un
débat apaisé les seuls débats qu'on a
aujourd'hui dans la société
sur ces questions qui sont des questions
qui touchent absolument tout le monde
ces deux minutes sur des chaînes
d'information continue faut envoyer la
petite phrase qui fera du buzz
ici on a pris le temps de discuter
d'exploser et on peut avoir un débat
apaisé bien fait le gouvernement
respecte je lis et cyril hanouna en
malgache ça veut dire débat apaisé
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
est ce que fait ou que eric naulleau
vous a convaincu ou à gâteau proulx
alors alors qui vous a plus convaincus à
gâteaux pour eric naulleau c'est rigolo
[Applaudissements]
et oui c'est la prime au champion qui
seront en finale dans un instant avec le
bizutage est sur la question de la pma
parce qu'eric est vous avez été très bon
tous les deux ans c'est du 60-40 juste
sur la question d'appeler ma la pma donc
la procréation médicalement assistée est
ce que vous êtes pour aux comptes pour à
57%
il comptera 43 % c'est quand même assez
partagés